what here without ya let me tell you
exactly what the title of greetings
[ __ ] uncle Joey here breaking
into your [ __ ] afternoon with
late breaking news a broadcast is about
to start so my man Rudy Sarzo is here
the christ-killers here and all we need
is you I'm just doing a few bong hits to
get the [ __ ] blood going I'm saying
gotta raise the blood pressure whenever
I come to you [ __ ] I don't even
take blood medication when I come over
here with you [ __ ] that's a
little half a [ __ ] [ __ ] blow up there
that's like a George Clooney Bungay I'm
saying I got to give you an uncle Joey
bonnet straight from the nutsack hold on
here he comes
and we're smoking some debt this is
called patron og this was the last the
[ __ ] Pablo Escobar stash he had
hidden under a [ __ ] rock water mixed
with coke cat hairs I don't give a [ __ ]
bring it on you know I'm saying I got
the system of a [ __ ] billy goat I'll
smoke anything at this point I want to
give a shout-out to my Armenian burg
that [ __ ] ain't a petrified star
last night and a mushroom cap I hope it
stay at the hotel hospital was easy it's
[ __ ] we gave him a petrified star
that's a star that sits under a table
for a year and the fat grows off it and
just it just magnitudes and strength
it's like a [ __ ] crack rock the
[ __ ] THC so when you come to the
Sugar Shack aka the Voodoo Lounge I have
a [ __ ] couple new uh petrified stars
for you Sam but Joey what's what they've
beaten you have no [ __ ] bong in and
what I know I know I know
pilot to Bombardier that's what we're
talking about George Clooney can suck my
dick you understand me
that's a [ __ ] bong it and if we're
gonna do one we might as well do two you
know what this Cubans don't walk on one
leg
I'm saying we attack everything you
never see doing the cube when doing a
bump of coke he does too cuz he wants to
get balanced out you don't want that
like twitching you know thing and the
whole of this thing that way but don't
bother get the hello humping down a
family boy the highest law said it it's
a ho-hum day but [ __ ] it if you're
freezing your ass off go [ __ ] yourself
you made a bad choice I'm over here
living like a [ __ ] doctor with a
t-shirt on my pants
in fact my nut fell out today it was
sweating so if you're freezing you made
a bad [ __ ] choice go [ __ ] yourself I
don't be able to [ __ ] about the
earthquake I don't give a [ __ ] at the
Korean sends a missile it's 80 degrees
today alright that's not that matters
it's 80 degrees today it's 80 [ __ ]
degrees I went out with like a hood it's
which and I'm watching the news and had
to take it off with the two [ __ ]
minutes I was sweating fog you penguins
[ __ ] you all well here living like
doctors Robin SPF number two one you
know saying
pilot to Bombardier [ __ ]
Wow my lung feels [ __ ] tremendous you
understand you gotta work along every
day I got like a half of lung but I work
it baby
a couple kettlebells some jujitsu and
some reefer two minutes youtube.com
slash seats last Joey did my uncle
Rudi's here looking beautiful beautiful
he can't do bong hits yet because he's
got bursitis bronchitis cousins to
bursitis and his [ __ ] hurts you know
how that goes he needs a bong and I blow
that [ __ ] beside this right out of
his lung old-school style
don't forget Happy New Year write your
goals and everything is gonna come true
in 2018 how do I know cuz I [ __ ]
waited for the miracle to happen don't
give up on American [ __ ] it
happens the miracle is you scratch your
balls sniff your fingers and tell God
thank you for giving me another day I'm
gonna go out there and make somebody
suck my dick today with talent not all
the Harvey I'm saying you'll end up in a
rehab with a bunch of [ __ ] tell
each other secrets or bad breath anyway
stay black two minutes youtube.com / c /
Joey Diaz think about it [ __ ]
always have good breath when somebody
tells you that chick sucks a thousand
pics the breath is [ __ ] mint and fresh
people's don't suck dick their bread
smells like Pig you ever notice that
Food for Thought it's like when you it's
like when you eat healthy your farts
smell worse you know even though there's
that eat a bowl of salad your fart
people leave the [ __ ] world it's
amazing anyway food for thought like I
said scratch your balls
sniff your fingers and smoke victory cuz
that's what a victory comes from from
the harder your [ __ ] nutsack
you sniff that [ __ ] because a
reminder why the [ __ ] you here and what
your mission is today because you know
how we talk here or if they didn't get
my might than I bingo I go get the LOI
hey I said it didn't kill my mother my
pink eye with all the oil but boy a car
you know it's you know pasaron cool
anyway I'll see you in 10 minutes
youtube.com / ceaseless Joey Diaz